yeah but by the way why why are you
still in l.a are you like the last of
the mohicans are you looking good
hoping for larry elder for something to
turn around i am dude i am i
i want the santas to come over now
i'm so done with this but i uh you know
what man i got my kids uh my ex and my
my children from my first marriage are
there so i can't you know i i i can't
that's tough i keep got it there's no
way but if that wasn't the case i'd be
dominant okay so if that wasn't the case
me and john would have been like
shop too dude i we i looked at property
in nashville and in austin i looked at
it but you know you looked at nashville
yeah
rogan still calls me everybody's like
get to austin i'm like i got kids i'm
not gonna you know you're fine but i
tell you let me tell you my opinion my
opinion i don't want the austin
community to get upset at me i think
both austin and nashville is a pit stop
okay
i agree
and let me tell you why i'm gonna
explain to you why this is purely coming
from my own case study because my pit
stop was dallas sure so i lived in
dallas for five years and i said listen
this is a great place no taxes they love
hard workers they love capitalism plano
people work the most hours per week so
they're workers they're not people that
want to leave at 459 community they're
you know they're willing to do the job
i'm three hours so i'm like this is it
babe we're going to stay here
how about the fifth year you're like you
know what i'm you know this we kind of
like this place called breakers and we
kind of like la and we kind of like what
texas offers and if texas and la had a
baby it'd be florida you know what why
don't we just move to florida so i think
nashville and austin i think is a pit
stop and i think it's about three to
five years until that pit stop is
valuable favorite my favorite audiences
yeah
and in many ways my favorite place in
the world is miami really yeah because
all i want to be at the end of the day
is cuban or
at least are you married now or no i i
am i have a fiance but
yeah
i'm actually i mean
i'm just shocked that you said your
favorite audiences are miami because
they can't pay attention to a freaking
favorite they want to worry about the
club and go partying and talking to them
that that they have a secret look and by
the way yeah i mean if you want
cuban venezuela colombian the the women
not that i look another i have a girl
guys that would never but
naturally it changes it's out of control
and brian has a bit where you want to be
like a splatter dancer
ask me where i'm from i'm gonna be
romantic but well where are you from
just like i'm from the mountains my
friends spain
lots of different places but spain it's
my heart
with my house
so you're getting paid to just want to
be that guy i just wanna say romantic
[ __ ] all the time so you gotta you gotta
play well you gotta play a movie where
you can do that one again
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]